よろしくお願いします
それで あの なんでこの鹿の例えが出てくるんですかというと
この昔インドでは鹿の肉を食べていたんですね
ですから この森に入って狩りをしようと思ったら
だいたい鹿を狙っちゃうんですね
で なんかすごい好物でしたみたいし
かなり鹿の話が出てくるんです
狩人たちもやっぱり罠かけたりすると
だいたい鹿に罠をかけたりして捕まって肉を売ったりするんですね
ですから それは一般的な例えになっているんです
それで このラッタパーラ長老が王様の鹿がいる森に入ったところで
昼はその森の中にいたんですね
アタコーラジャコーラビヨミガワンアマンテッシーソーデーヒサンマミガワミガーチェーランウイヤナブーミンガッチャマスブーミンダッサナーヤーティ
そこでコーラウェ王様が
自分の誰でしたっけ？そうですか
庭の番人 庭園の番人とか
名前ですね ウィジャナパーラの名前
元の意味は猟師  うん まあ名前ではないと思いますけど
猟師かもしれません とにかくこの森の番人ですね
で 彼にこの まあ遊ぶところはありましたから
それを綺麗にしなさいと
用意しなさいと 私はただ遊びに行きますよということでね
綺麗になった森を見たいんだと
エヴ
ァンデーヴァティコーミガオーサンニューコーラウヤスパティストゥッワミガチェーランソーデントアッダサアヤスマンタンラッタパーランアンニャタラスニドッカムーレディワヴィハランニシンナン
そこで王様に返事をして
この彼がこの森に入って森をいろいろ準備するんですね
王様が入るために そこである木の下でラッタパーラ長老が座っているのを見つかるんです
ディッスワナイエナラジャコーラヴィョーテーヌプサンカミプサンカミットワラジャナンコーラウヤンエタダボーチャ
王様に森をていれて報告する
スッダンコーデーヴァミガチェーランアッティチェッカラッタパーローナマクナプットーイマスミンエーワトゥッラコッティテーアッガクニカッサプットーヤッサトワ
ンアビンナンキッタエマノーアホーシソーアンニャタラスミンルッカムーレディワヴィハランニシンノーティ
王様が入るんだから一般人が入ってはいけないんですけど
本当はそこでそれぐらいのことだと思いますけど
猟師というか その番人がいて
森を全部調べて 人々がいるんだったら追い出しちゃうっていうことだと思いますけど
でもいたらこの森の中でもラッタパーラ長老が座ってるんですね
ですから 出家の人々は追い出すことはしません
どうしますかと王様に相談するんです
で 一応どんな出家の どんな集出家の出家の方々も
だいたいこの街に入ったら
王様の公園とかそういうところで自由に入って泊まったりするんです
で そこは誰も断りはしません
そういうことだから オープンな場所なんです
それも王様に言うんですね
街は森はきれいになりましたと
そこでラッタパーラ このトゥッラコッティという町の息子であったこのラッタパーラも
その森の中にある木の下に座ってるんだと
そこでこのラッタパーラっていうのは
王様がよく褒めてた人だと
王様がなんか王様のなんかかなり気に入った人みたいですね
ですから 王様はよくいつでも話していたラッタパーラがお坊ちゃんが今出家して帰って森の中にいるんだと
それで王様のことや テーナヒサンマニガワアランダーナアッジャウッヤーナブーミヤン
ブーミヤ テーネーワダーニマヤンバガヴァヴァワンタンラッタパランパイルーパシッサーマティ
この聞いたところで で
だったらまあ今日は遊ぶことやめましょう
このラッタパーラ長老に会って彼と付き合いしましょうと
アタコーラージャコーラヴィヨヤンタッヘカーダニヤンボージャニヤンパティヤッタンタンサッバンウィッサッウィッサッジェターティワッター
いろいろ食べ物といっぱい用意していますけど
それを全部置いときなさいよと
持っていかないと
バドラニバドラニヤーナニヨージャペッバーバドラゴンヤーナンアビルーヒットゥアーバドレヒバドレヒヤーネヒトゥルラコッティックトゥルラトッコッティックタ
ンハーニーヤシマッチャラージャヌマハラージャヌバーヴェーナアヤスマンタンラッタパランダッサナーヤ
別に簡単なことで まあいろいろ乗り物に乗って行きましたっていうことですね
大王の王様のように ヤーヴァティカーヤーナッサブーミヤーネーナガンファーヤーナアッチョーローヒッファーパッティコーワウッサターヤウッサターヤパリサーヤ
テーナアヤスマラッタパーロテーナプサンカムニ
まあ車で行けるところまで行って
それからみんなで歩いて行きました
行ってラッタパーラ長老のところに来て
ラッタパーラ長老にと一緒にいろいろお話をして
傍らに座りましたと そこから経典の内容に入るんです
エーカマンタンティトーコーラージャコーラヴィヨアヤスマンタンラッタパランエータダボーチャ
イダバワンラッタパーローカッタットレニッシーダトゥーティ
王様がこの まあ自分も座りたいし
ラッタパーラ長老も座って欲しいんですね
ただもうただの木の下に座っているんだから
それで王様が大体座るときは
象に乗っていく場合はかなり大きい豪華な椅子みたいなものをつけるあるんですね
それはもう象の体の上につけて
その中に座ってかなり気楽に行くんですね
まあ象もちょっと体揺れますから
歩くときは まあそれも感じないように
もう結構すごい豪華なものなんですね
それは大体王様 床に土足が座る時でも
それを降ろしてもらって
そちらに座る 王様がこのもう象に使うね
その座るものって言って
お坊さんがそちらに座ってくださいと
そしたらお坊さんがアランマハラージャニッシーディトゥワンニッシーダトゥワンニッシーノーハンサケヤーサネ
このお坊さんがいいですよと
あなたはそちらに座ってください
私は自分座っているところで大丈夫ですよと
一応お坊さんたちにはこの象につけるものを
それから馬に使う ものとか
そういうものでは座ってはいけないという風に解りつつもあります
それもあまりにも豪華なもので
何かそういうものを座って座ってはいけないんだと
そこで王様が質問するんです
チャ
ッターリマニボーラッタカラパリジュンナニエーヒパリジュンエーヒサマンナガターイデーカッチェーケサマッスンオーハーレットワーカーサーヤーニワッターニアッ
チャーデットワーガーラスマーナガーリアンパンバジャンティーカタマニチャッターリジャラーパリジュンニャンジャーディパリジュンニャンボーガパリジュンニャンニャーティパリジュンニャン
で それあの その通りに訳出てみましょう
日本訳になると  ページ の
のところですね 王様の質問はまあ
次のような四つの破滅があります
人間にとってはいろいろな破滅が四つありますと
その破滅を経験するならば
そこである者たちは髪と髭をそり
声衣をまとい 家を捨てて出家します
四つとは何でしょうか
老いの破滅 病の破滅 財産の破滅
親族の破滅ですと そこで王様が考えたのは
普通は人間にはいろいろ不幸が出てくるんですね
だから破滅することも破壊
倒産することというのは四つありますと
まあ一番目はこの えーと
何でしたっけ  年取ることですね
老いの破滅 まあすごく年取ってしまって
もう生活もう家族の中で生活できなくなる
仕事もできなくなることね
二番目は病気になってしまったら
重病になってしまったら
またもう治らない病気とかね
ありますからね すぐ治る病気だったら病気だと言えませんだけど
まあやっぱり治らない病気になってしまう
そうすると仕事もできないし
再起して生活もできなくなって
もう破滅になると それから財産な破滅はまあいつでもあることで
親族の破滅っていうのは親族みんな死んでしまうしまう場合なんですね
それもまあよくまあ欲と言ったっても
人間にはあることで 今も世の中でいろんなところでまあなっちゃうし
日本でもね いきなり地震なんか起きて
もう全部倒れちゃうところでね
もう最近もありましたしね
まあ一日にして親族みんな亡くなっちゃって
一人だけ残ってしまっちゃうとかね
で 他の国々でもね 洪水でやらいろんなことでもみんな死んじゃって
もう一人だけ残しちゃうとかね
そうすると生きていられないんですね
自分一人だけ残されちゃって
全部親族が消えてしまったらね
そういうふうなことで
人間にとってはもう生きていられなくなっちゃうんですね
それでどうしようもないんだから
じゃあ出家でもして まあ修行でもしますと
もう俗世間をやめますとと思っちゃうんですね
例えば年取って それはインドでよく普通にあったことで
人が年取ってしまっちゃうと
財産は全部子供たちに任せて自分が家を出るんですよ
老人になっちゃったら家を出て出家する
で 出家して そこでまあどこかでまあこそこそと生きていて
まあ修行なりのことをなんとかして
まあ亡くなってしまっちゃうんですね
で 病気の場合も同じことで
そういう四つの破滅のことを言ってるんですね
そこでパーリ語でまた説明するんですね
説明ありますね 私は損しました
カタ
マンチャボーラッタパラジャラーパリジュンニャンイッダボーラッタパラエーカッチョージンノーホーティブッドーマハンレクアッダガトゥーワヨワヌッパットーソー
イティパティサンチッカティアハンコーミエータラヒジンノーブッドーマハンレクアッダガトゥーワヨワヌッパットーノコーパナマヤーシュカランアナディガターワボー
ガアディガントゥンアディガターワボーガパートゥンカートゥンパーティンカートゥンヤンノーナーハンケーサマッスンオーハーレットワーカーサーヤーニワッターニ
アッチャーデットワーアガーラスマーナガーリアンパッバジェイアンティー
年取った人はそういうふうに考えるんだと
私は年取ってもうボロボロになってるんだと
私にはこの新しく財産作ることもできません
アナディガターワボーガ
ない財産を新しく仕事をして生むこともできませんし
えーと  常に元気にいることを約束できない
アディガターワーボーガー
まあ自分今持ってる財産もパーティンカートン増やすこともできないし
ですから まあ出家してしまいましょうと
ということで出家する
決めちゃうんですね ソーテーナジャラーパールジュンネーナサマンナーガと
そうやって年取ったことによって
年の老い老いるという破滅になってしまって出家するんだと
それが一番目だと 老い老いの破滅だと
バワンコーラッタパーラターロエータラヒダハローユワススカーラケーソバドレーナヨッベレーナサマンナーガトパテメーナワエサー
でもラッタパーラさんは今大変若いんだと
ダハローっていうのはまだ子供だよという意味ですね
ユワっていうのは若いんですね
で  で  ススはどんな訳でしたっけ
漆黒の黒い髪 髪の毛  カーラケーソーの黒髪でしょう
カーラケーソー髪です
黒い髪ですね  漆ですか
漆ない  漆黒って書いてあるけど
ん？ 漆黒 漆黒いと  あ そうですか
漆ですか えっと 私はページも見失っちゃったんだから
ページ の  真ん中の方  はい
行目です  ああ これ読み方は漆黒
うん で まあすごい あの
いわゆるまあ若くて 髪の毛はまだまだすごく黒くて
バドレーナヨッベレーナ
大変素晴らしい若者でいるんではないか
パテメーナワエサー 人生の三段階に分けたら
まだまだまだ段階目にいるんですね
いわゆるまあ 少年中年老年としちゃえば
まだ少年時代に入ってるんですね
タンボーとラッタパーラッサジャラーパーリジュンニャンナッティ
ですから ラッタパーラさんには別に老い老い
老いの破滅ということはないでしょうと
キンバワンラッタパーロニャッツーワーディスワーワーすっツーワーワーアガーラスマナガーリャンパッバジトーと
そこでラッタパーラさんが何を知って
何を見て 何を聞いて出家したんでしょうか
いわゆるなんであなたは出家したんでしょうかという意味なんですね
こんなにも少年時期にいまだにいるのに
老い老いの破滅だったら分かりますけどね
そうでもないのはちょっとわかりませんということなんです
そこで二番目説明しますね
カタ サンチャボーラッタパーラヴャーディパーリジュニャン
イドボーラッタパーラエーカッチョーアーバーディコーホーティドゥッキトーバルラギラーノソーイティパティサンチッキャティ
アハンコーミーエータラヒーアーバーディコードゥッキトーバルラギラーノヌコーパナマヤ
スカラーンアナディガターヴァーボーガアディガントゥンアディガットヴァーヴァーボーガン
ファトゥンカートゥンヤンヌーナアンケーサマッスンオーハーレットヴァーカーサーヤーニワッターニアッチャデットヴァーアガーラスマナガーリャンパッバジェイヤンティ
っていうところで 病気になった人がアーバーディコー
バルラギラーノ 病気に倒れているんですね
それで彼が考えるんですよ
私にはもう財産を生むことも
持っている財産を増やすことも何もできません
ですから出家しますよと
それで彼がそうやって出家するでしょうと
それが病の破滅です でもラッタパーラさんがエータラヒアッバーバード
もうそんな病気は少ない
ないんだと アッパータンコ
アーバーとアタンカと両方病気のことなんですけど
日本語で何かそこら辺頑張ってますかね
いや 健康で患いがなく育たえてます
うんうん  病気が少ないことを健康という
通訳さんは最初がノデュオ
ん？ ノデュオ あろうが
うん  病が 苦悩ない  うんうん
そうですね サンウェーバーキニア
サマウェーバーキニアガハニアサマンナーガと
サマウィパっていうのは
元気いっぱいという意味で
もう食べるものはちゃんと消化できるし
走ったり歩いたり もう喧嘩したり
もう何でもできるし もうすぐそうやってものすごい元気いっぱいの年でしょうと
サマンナーガと ナーティシーターヤ
ナーティウンナーヤっていうのですかね
お腹の状態でしょうね
これはインドの考え方で
このシータ・ウンナっていうのは体の一つ特色を表しているんですよ
で そのシータっていうのは寒いということで
その特色入っちゃうと
もうすごい体の調子が悪くなっちゃって
もう食べることも消化することもできないし
病気になってしまうし
ウンナっていうのは熱すぎということで
そこかかっちゃったら
食べることは食べられますけど
激しく反応するんですね
体 食べるものに ですから
またいろいろ病気が出てきたりするんですね
目が痛いし 胸は痛いとかね
皮膚がいろいろ荒れたりとかね
そういうことを言ってるんです
そこをまた食べ物で調整するんですね
医者は で シータての寒すぎの体だったら
熱いと思う食べ物を食べさせちゃうし
熱すぎの体だったら寒いという感じる
考えてる食べ物を食べさせて体冷やすと思うんですね
そんなこと何もなくて
ちょうどバランス整っている時期でしょうと
あなたの場合は ですから
あなたにとっては病の破滅はない
ですから あなたなんで出家したんでしょうかと
そこでボーガパーリジュニャン
カタマンチャボーラッタパーラボーガパーリジュニャン
イドボーラッタパーラエーカッチョーアッドホーホーティマハッダノマハーボーゴ
で ラッタパーラ時々人がものすごい財産がある
アッドーっていうのはもう裕福であって
マハッダノ たくさん 財産
ダナっていうのはお金のことで
マハーボーゴっていうのは財産のこと
土地やらね いろいろ財産のこと
アッドーっていうのは満たしているということで
裕福であると 時々人々が大変裕福で
お金もあって 他の財産のある人はいるでしょうと
タッサテーボーガアヌプッベーナパリッキャンガッチャンと
その財産はどんどん消えてしまうと
で 彼がこう考えるんですね
私はもう大変財産があったんだけど
もう全部財産がなくなったと
また私には新しい財産を作ることもできないんだから出家しますよと
それは財産の破滅 それでラッタパーラさんの場合
バワンコーパナラッタパーロイマスメンギエワトゥッラコッティテーアッガクオリカッサプット
あなたはこのトゥッラコッティタ村の一番上の家で生まれているでしょうと
タンボートーラッタパーラッサボーガパーリブジュニャンナーマナッティ
ですから あなたには財産の破滅は全くないんだと
いわゆるこの一番上の家っていうのは
やっぱり一番金持ちの家っていう意味に取っているんですね
キンバワンラッタパーロニャットワディスワスットワアガーラスマナガリャンパッバジタン
あんた何を考えて出家したんでしょうかと
そこでニャーティパーリジュニャン
親戚が亡くなることで
である人々にバフーホンティミッターマッチャーニャーティサーローヒター
たくさん親戚たちがいるんだと
で ニャーティカーっていうのはこの違う家から来る親戚たちです
いわゆるこの結婚の関係で出来上がるニャーティ
サーローヒターっていうのは血縁
血縁 血縁関係の親戚ですね
ミッターマッチャーっていうのは
まあもう何といいますか
付き合ってる人々のこと
知り合いとかね ことなんですね
たくさんの友人たちがいて
それでタッセーニャータカアヌブッデーナパリッキャンガッチャンって
もうなんとかわけがあって
どんどん消えてしまうと
それで彼が考えるんですね
私の親戚が全部亡くなりました
知人 知人たちもみんな消えてしまった
一人ぼっちになりました
それで私にはもう商売をやることはできないんだと
で 出家しますよと ここで出家するんだと
それでボートーコーパンラッタパーラッサイマスミンゲーワトゥッラコッティテーバフーミッターマッチャーニャーティサーローヒター
でもラッタパーラサンニワこのトゥッラコッティテも町でたくさん知人たちも親戚もいるでしょうと
ですから あなたには親戚の破滅もない
ですから あなたなんで出家したんですかと
キンバワンラッタパーローニャッダーワディスワーワスッダーワパッバジトーティと全部まとめて王様が質問するんですね
そしてその王様の質問っていうのはすごい代表的な質問で
まあ簡単に言えばね まあなんであんた出家したんですか？という質問なんですけど
でも えっとまあ 日本では出家習慣ないんですから
まああまりわからないかもしれませんだけど
えっと インドではね まあ一般的なことで
出家っていうのは仏教のことだけじゃないんですよ
どんな宗教の場合でも
家を離れて出家するということですから
あのインド ヒンドゥー文化ではやっぱり決まってるんですね
もう元気で まあ財布で
喜びながらいられるんだったらそれやると
金儲かることできるんだったら金儲かることばっかりしているんだと
で まあ元気だったら一生懸命仕事をしながら生活するんだと
何もできなくなっちゃうと出家するんだというふうな考え方あったんですね
ですから 出家っていうのは社会生活できなかった人々の溜まり場ような感じで考えられてたんですね
ですから まあ出家して
例えば若い人なんか出家してると
あんたまだ若いのに もうなんで出家してるんですかと
その質問しちゃうと 出尊する人の考え方は
ただ世俗世間で奢って生活することは最高に素晴らしいことであって
できなかったら出家するのもいいんだけど
もうそれできるんだったら
世の中で もう俗世間で
もう バリバリ頑張って金儲けて生きていなさいっていうことなんですね
だからその思考っていうのは世界で一般的にあることで
我々に学校でもどこでも教えてくれるのは
ただそれだけなんですね
とにかく儲かりなさい
とにかくお金を作りなさい
それで結婚して子供を作って
とことんもう権力を握って
会社作るんだったらもう片っ端から世界中でもいいんだから作り作って
ものを作るんだったらもうむちゃくちゃ作作って売りさばいて儲かりなさい
ただそれしか教えてくれないんですね
それは何のためかと それは人類の役に立つんですかと
それは人間の生き方ですかと何一つも教えてくれないんで
学校では ただ儲かりなさい
だから親も両親も子供たちにそれしか教えてあげないんですね
とにかく勉強しなさい
とにかくいい学校に入りなさい
とにかくいい会社に入りなさいと
これ 何のためにでしょうかと
それが人生ですかと そこは教えてくれないんで
だから全く幻覚の世界で生きてるんですね
ただ それためにそれだけですか
人生っていうのは 女性の場合だったら
そこら辺もなんとか勉強して
もう年になってきたら誰かと結婚して
それで子供を作ると それだけですか
人間の人生の価値っていうのは
男だったらむちゃくちゃむちゃくちゃ喧嘩もしながら
人を殺しでもしながら
とにかく金儲かると そこでじゃあ儲かって
自分の子供のために仕事をしているんだと言ったって
それでもそうでもないでしょうに
子供も同じことをしなくちゃいけないんだから
だから親が一生懸命大金持ちになってしまったって
子供にとって意味がないんだよ
子供は自分でまた仕事をしなくちゃいけない
逆に親が財産残して死んじゃったんだから
私は仕事をしませんと言ったら
それだけで子供の人生破滅になっちゃうんですね
全部無駄遣いするだけで
もう大変悪いことを麻薬やらいろんなことに手を出したりして
もう刑務所で終わっちゃうんですね
人生は ですから 子供も同じことをしなくちゃいけないし
親も同じことをしなくちゃいけないし
孫も同じことをしなくちゃいけないんです
だから 世の中の人生論というのはね
それぐらいのこと その考え方で
世界中どんな人間でも
その考え方 その考え方でもやられているんですね
だから どんな国にどんな人に聞いても
幸せな人生って何でしょうかと
いっぱいお金儲けて それだけなんです
あまりにも単純すぎですね
仏教から見れば たったそれだけですかと
だから私はそれをちょっとすくって大げさに言うんですよ
私はものすごい失礼な言葉なんですけど
私は言うのは その生き方っていうのは
犬と猫の野生の動物の生き方とは全く変わってないでしょうと
わざとそういうことを言うんですね
あなた方の生き方っていうのは
犬とどこか違いますか？と
言うと みんなすごいプライド傷ついちゃって向かって来ますからね
それは狙って言ってるんです
そう向かってこないと頭が全然開いてくれないんです
永久的に この間違ってるこの思考で
とにかく勉強することを人生やとにかく金儲かることを人生
それ以上喋るなよと ということでいるんです
それなのに なんでみんなお寺に来るんですかというと
まあもう何て言いますか
学学業成就とかね 商売繁盛とか家内安全とか
いわゆるちょっと失敗すると
この金儲かる世界でちょっとお寺にこそこそと来て
なんとかなんとかなんとかとお願いして
それだけのことで そこでどんなお寺でも神社でもね
ちょっといてお参りしたところで
子供が試験合格しちゃったら
もうそのお寺やら神社やら
そのお祈りの場所を一生懸命宣伝する
あちらで私は本当にお札かったところで
子供は本当にもうなんとか大学をもう受かったんですよと言ったら
みんなおお 他の人々もさっとそれがね
群がって それでまた自分たちがすごい宗教的な人々だと
またもう見え張るところもすごいところなんですね
だからあれは宗教でも何でもないんですね
ただ 世俗世間でも金儲かる世界でちょっと心配があると
ちょっといて なんとかお祈りしてもらう
祈祷してもらうだけの生き方なんです
ですから このつまらないのも呆れるほどつまらないんですよ
僕たちから見れば それだけですから
ですから この犬と猫と何が違いますか？とわざと言うのは
もうやっぱり怒ってほしいんです
なんで我々のプライド傷つくんですかと
だから我々にこの学校やら社会やら教えてくれる教え
道徳やら学問というのは本当にぴったしその通りで正しいかと
役に立つかということは考えなくちゃいけないんですよ
もっと楽な生き方あるはずなんですね
子育てだけに一生かかってしまうと
これちょっとおかしいんじゃないかとね
あるいはもう仕事をすることだけに全て人生かかってしまっちゃうと
それはちょっとおかしいんじゃないかと
もっと人間に生きる喜び
余裕があって 気持ちよく生きる喜びを味わう思考があるはずなんですけど
どうそれをもう初めからもう忘れていたんですね
それはこの欲ばっかし出てきただからなんで
余計なことを考えたんだからなんです
だからまあそのポイントなんですね
ここら辺で一応あの解読しようとしているのは
ですから 当時インドの人々から見ても
金も受けて たくさん子供を作って
まあ死ぬ それこそ人生やと
できない人々はまあ出家でもしてみてくださいという
だからすごいゴミ扱いですね
出家世界は そこを壊したのはお釈迦様なんです
堂々ともう元気で もうすごい若い時
もう 二十八歳で出家して
それでみんな驚いちゃったよ
なんで 二十八歳なのに
お釈迦様はすぐ見つけたんです
私は今皆様に教えたところ
こんなこれは罠だと 引っ掛けだと
仕事をしなさいと 金儲けて
お釈迦様の場合はね 王様にならなくちゃあかんだからね
あなたの仕事は王様になって国を管理することやと
王様になったら楽かてとんでもないことでしょうに
隣の国が勝手に攻めてきたら
これはまた行って戦争しなくちゃいけないでしょうに
それで殺されちゃう場合もあるでしょうに
殺されなくたってもひどい怪我したり
足を切断されたりとかね
毒を飲まされたりとか
いくらあるでしょうに
ですから 毎日この食べ物に毒が入っているでしょうかとか
チェックしながら食べる人生幸せですかね
王様になって 我々は庶民だからね
王様っていうのはいいなあ
あんなすごい乗り物に乗って
すごいあのね いろんな宝石を被っている
あのそこや 毎日心配でご飯食べる時でも
エジプトの世界でもものすごく平気で毒殺とかね
あったりしたんだから
ツタンカーメンでしたっけ
これ有名なね 物語で 若いしね
まだまだ青年でしょうに
もう殺されちゃったんだから
ですから それも罠でしょうに
結局幸せで生きていることに邪魔する罠だけなんです
我々それわかってない
仏教じゃないんですよ
皆様の幸せになって幸せに邪魔しているのは
この世界なんですよ 勉強しなくちゃ
大きな建物を作らなくちゃ
たくさん金儲けなくちゃとかね
それで幸せに生きていたらなくなってるだけです
そこでおかしいことに我々に文句を言うんだよ
あんた方はね 酒飲んではいけませんとかね
言うんだから迷惑ですよ
そんなことは なんで人間の幸せに邪魔してるんですかと
こっちでも略取するんですよ
あんたが だから仏教は平気でこの愚か者という言葉を使っているのは愚か者やと
他の言葉をお釈迦様にないんです
言うためには 自分たちで幸せにならないように仕掛けを作って
そこでむちゃくちゃ苦しみながら
憂い悲しみの人生 生まれた時から死ぬまで
それで賭け事なんかやめなさいと言ったら
なんであんた我々のせっかくの幸せに邪魔するんですかと
そういう風にも文句を言うんだから
そのポイントですね この経典で一応広げようとしているのは
だからお釈迦様もやっぱりこれは罠だよと思って
それ出て行って出家っていうのはそういうことじゃないんだと
このこのいわゆる仮有働が罠を引っ掛けている
その餌を食うなよと 逃げましょうと言って
この世俗的な思考から逃げる
思考から逃げる でも生き方からも逃げて
この心の幸せを見つかるという
ですから 人間の中で人間乗り越えて光り輝いて生きていると
かすかな苦しみもなく生きていると言って
悟ってから初めて笑えるんだと
人間の笑い方のお釈迦様にあれは泣いているんだと
みんな笑っているでしょうに
やっぱり幸せで笑ってる
あれ泣いてるんだと 歌にははっきりと歌はもうあれはもう嘆き声というんですか
泣き声 泣き声だと ものすごく悲しくて
あれはもうたまらなくなって
あれ泣いてるんだと 別に喜んでいるわけじゃないんだと
まああの歌は聴いてるとやっぱり全部泣きでしょうに
ポピュラーソングであろうか
演歌であろうが 一つも喜びを語っていないでしょうに
泣いてます 泣いていることを聞いたら悲しくなるんでしょうしね
悲しくなっちゃって なんで楽しいと言うんですかね
悲しいと言うべきところ
私は歌を聴きながら やっぱり無意味だな
無駄だなとね 本当にもうもうすっごくイライラするんですよ
聴く時は で なんか人間を感情を引き起こすといって一生懸命工夫するでしょ？歌ってる人々は
工夫するんだけど 下手なところでもう全然そちらこちらは乗れないし
それから手ぶり身ぶりでね
いろいろ可愛い顔したりとか
もういい加減にせんかという気持ちになっちゃうしね
もう下手だったら黙っていなさいよと
でも向こうは黙ってられませんね
それで有名になって もう財産
人財産作りたいし それでも並ならぬ苦労するし
結果として歌ももう聞いていられないし
やっと聞いていたっても二
三週間でもう消えちゃうしね
残る歌っていうのはほんのちょっとでしょう
もう何万個も歌ある世界
日本の世界にしても 本当に歴史的に残っている歌っていうのはほんの数少ないんだからね
そういうことですから
お釈迦様はこの罠から逃げていくということですから
仏教の出家っていうのはそれと違うんですね
そこでこのサッリプッタ尊者がやっと答えるんです
やっとではなくて 私はやっとにしたんですけど
アッティコマーラジャテーナバガワタジャータパスタアラハタサンマサンブッダチャッタロダンムッデーサウディッディッタ
イエハンニャッワチャディッスワチャスッワチャカーラスマナガリヤンパッバジトゥ
カタメチャッタロ そこでこの王様が四つの破滅を語ったんだから
サッリプッタ尊者も四つにまとめて答えるんですね
そこで我々のお釈迦様が
ブッダが四つの法を説いているんだと
ダンマウッデーサは法門かな
ウッデーサは略して説いたと
ウッデーサっていうのはこのまあ諺みたいな感じで
表現というかね なんか有名な文句みたいな
そういう意味なんですね
格言ですね 格言ですね
そういう お釈迦様が四つの格言を
法の格言を教えているんだと
その四つの法を聞いて
それを体験して知って
私は出家しましたと カタメチャッタロ
四つは何でしょうか ウパニーヤティローコアッドホーティコマーラジャテーナバガワタジャータパッサタラータサンマサンブッダパタマウダンウッデーサウディット
それ一番 ウパニーヤティローコアッドホー
言葉ミスなんです ウパニーヤティローコアッドホー
世界は安定なものとして
導かれるという あと説明入りますからね
それを聞いて私は出家しましたと
二番目 アッターノローコアナビッサラ
えーと  世界は保護所がないもの
保護者がない 百八十七の一番最後の行です
うんうんうん 世界は救護所がないもの
保護者がないものであるという
えーと 三番目はアッサコーローコサッバンパハウェガマニーヤン
その四行すごい短いんです
えーと 世界は  自己の所有がなく
全てを捨てていかねばならない
四番目 ウーノローコアティットタンナーダーソ
世界はあることのない
あることのない 渇愛の奴隷である
世界は渇愛の奴隷であると
その四つを聞いて理解して
私は出家しましたと そう言っても
まあどうせ当然王様がわからないんですね
それで質問するんですね
ウパニーヤティローコアッドーティバワンラッタパローアーハ
イマッサパナボーラッタパラバーシタッサカタンアットーダッタンボー
ラッタパラさんはこの
えーと 世界は あの 何に導かれる？あの不安定なものとして導かれると言ったんですけど
その意味はどういうふうに理解すればよろしいでしょうかと
大体この まあ私たちにもちょっとした悪い習慣がありまして
この人が何か言葉言ったら
言葉の あの まあ言葉は言葉だから言葉は分かってますよ
それで終わっちゃうんです
それは良くないんですよ
だからこの 例えばまあ世界は
も  あの 不安定です うん
そうです うん そうですね
それ そんな簡単に納得するのは良くないんですよ
それは本当は理解してないんで
ただ不安定という単語は知っている
世界という単語を知ってるっていうことだけのことなんです
ですから やっぱりものをちゃんと知りたいんだったら
自分が聞き慣れてる言葉を言っても
それはどういう意味ですか？どういう風にあなた解釈しますか？なぜそう思いますか？という風に
このいろいろ質問出して出して
その人の説明 解釈を受け取れないと
聞いてもらわないと 勉強したことにはならないんですね
そこら辺 パーリ経典でははっきり知っていて
あの まず項目を出します
格言を それで格言の言葉をみんな知ってます
知ってますけど これどんな意味？とまた先に聞くんですね
これはどんな意味ですかと聞くのは決して恥ずかしいことじゃないんです
聞かないことが恥ずかしいんですよ
あんた言ってることの意味は何でしょうかと
聞かないで分かったようなふりすること自体が恥ずかしいんですよ
はい どうせ人間が語ることだから
その人は何考えてるかっていうと
わからないのは当然なことで
ですから質問しない方がいいじゃない
そういう形式に これはまあ王様が自分勝手に説明してたんだけど
サッダパーラ尊者そうじゃなくて
まずつつの言葉だけ入れておいて止まっちゃうんですね
そこで聞きた 知りたければあなたの番ですよと
質問するの 王様がちゃんと正しく質問する
そこでちゃんと説得させる
サンキンマニュシマハーラージャアホーシトゥアンヴィーサティワッスッデーシコーピパンヌヴィーサティワッスッデーシコーピハッティスミンピカタヴィアッサスミン
ピカタヴィサタスミンピカタヴィダヌスミンピカタヴィタラスミンピカタヴィ
ウーロ ウーロバリバーババリアラマットゥサンガーナワチャローティ
だからそのまま訳で読めば簡単ですよ
大王よ そのことをどう思いますか？つまり
あなたは歳や歳の時には象
象に巧みであり 馬に巧みであり
車に巧みであり 弓に巧みであり
剣に巧みであり 桃への力もあり
腕の力もあり 勇気あり
そうですね ということですと
そこで王様がまあ その同じ言葉で答えるんですね
戦いにあの 秀でていましたと
サッダパーラ尊者よ ある時には私は神通
神通力さえあったような思われますと
若い時は私ね 本当にもう神通力でもあるんでしょうかと
自分でも不思議に思うほどえらい体力があったすごい人でしたね
自分の力に指摘するものは見えませんでしたと自慢までしてしまっちゃう
そこでサッダパーラ尊者は何のことなく
大王よ そのことをどう思いますか？つまり
あなたは今も全く同じように
ももの力もあり 腕の力もあり
地力もありと なんとか読むんですね
それで答え サッダパーラ尊者よ
そうではありません 今や私は老齢
老体 老体 老製の旅人となり
になっております  なっております
サッダパーラ尊者よ ある時には私はここへ一歩を出そうとして
別なところへ一歩出してしまう方ですと
今はみんなに支えられて歩いていると
歳だからね 大王よ について
見るお方であり さらに創始者であるかの手さんは
世界は不安定なものとして導かれると語られました
そうですね  そのことですよと
ちゃんと王様の心の中から説明するんですね
だから王様にとっては
それすごいもう気持ち悪いんですよ
だからものすごく力強くて
もう神通力でもあるんではないかと思うほどの力った人はね
もうみんなに支えられて歩いている
足は正しく踏めないし
もう間違っちゃうし そうするとやっぱりもうプライド傷ついちゃうんですね
みんな周りに来て もう昔は全然もう自分の若頃から見れば
あんな力もない人々に
今はね いろいろ面倒見てもらったりするとね
ですから それがお釈迦様おっしゃったんだ
だからウパニーヤティローコアッド
それから注釈しますけど
ウパニーヤティっていうのは導くという訳は直訳であって
このやっぱりどんどんこの世界は
まあなんて言いますか
そうなってしまう  とにかく破壊へというかね
まあ老いて壊れる方向へずっと進んでいるんですよ
それは世の中の真理なんで
だから子供が生まれたらどんどん成功
成長していくんじゃなくて
破壊へずっといくだけなんですね
どんなものでも現れた瞬間から壊れていくんですね
品物なんか買ったら 買った瞬間で新品ですけど
その秒からどんどんどんどん古くなっていく
我々も同じ どんなものでも同じ
そのスピードは止まることがないんです
今日生まれた赤ちゃんが同じスピードでずっと変化していくんですね
死ぬ瞬間まで だからどんな方向へ歩いていくかというと
この老いる方向へ 病気になる方向に向かって一生懸命走ってるんですよ
だから 明るいゴールに向かって走るんだったら応援できますけど
死を向かって頑張るぞと思って頑張ることは別に応援できませんね
私はよく頑張って生きてきたんだって言ったって
結局よく頑張って年取ったんだと
よく頑張って病気になったんだと
ものすごく頑張って年取ったんだっていうことなんで
それ頑張らなくたってもなるんですよ
だからそこら辺のこのおかしさですよ
仏教を見せをしているのは
それからそれ事実なんですね
それからもう何年間経っちゃうと
ソ連のミールという宇宙船落ちちゃうでしょうに
あれはもうかなり早いうちで
アメリカよりもかなり早いうちにそんなにちゃんとした宇宙ステーション作っちゃったんだから
だからものすごいことなんですけど
やっぱりそれでもどんどんどんどん品物が衰えていくんですよ
だからそのことで私は考えて
今アメリカも作りましょうと頑張ってますけど
ゆっくりゆっくりいろいろ部品持ってきてつなげるでしょ
こちら技術はどんどん発展する
向こうで部品が壊れていくと
もうもう衰えていく どうするんでしょうかと
同じことになると思いますよ
例えば新しいものをいろいろできちゃったら
向こうに持っていって繋げなくなっちゃうんですね
だからやめた方がいいんじゃないかなと
だってソ連がこの宇宙ステーションを送った時は
今みたいなこのすごい小型のコンピューターなんかはなかったんですね
それからこの一つの細い線でたくさんデータを送る光通信方法とかもなかったし
ですから 普通の当時であった普通のリード線で電力を送るは普通のコンピューター使ってましたし
それでもアメリカは進んでいたんだけど
それをもうもう五 六年経っちゃうと
前はもう二十キロのコンピューターでしたけど
まあ一キロで十分やとということになっちゃう
だからあるんだけど 持っていけないんですよ
持っていって繋げないんですね
他のもの だから全部持ってゴミにして
新しくそこで組み立てなくちゃいけない
そこまでは宇宙では無理ですね
いわゆる片っ端からこの空気の交換する機械から何から何までコンピューターコントロールでしょうね
ですから 完璧なこのもう一から宇宙で宇宙ステーションを作るってことは無理だから
それで捨てるしか道がなくなっちゃうんですね
同じこと もしかするとアメリカが無駄なお金を使ってやろうすることにもなる可能性はありますからね
どんどん成長しちゃうね
ですから どんな物事を見ても
やっぱりそうやって老化して
もう使い物でなくなっちゃうんですね
だから我々はそれは一生懸命苦労するんで
年取らないようにと 古くならないようにとかね
で 無駄な苦労をしているだけで
この時間の流れっていうのを止まることはできません
例えば人間っていうのは
例えば一 窒素にでも入っていれば死にませんよと
何の意味もないんですけどね
その場合とっくに死んでるんですけど
だから冷やしたりしていろんなことをして長持ちするようにすると
たとえ食べ物を冷蔵庫に入れておいたっても
その中でも老化はするんですよ
ですから この世の中っていうのは
そうやって全体的に全ての生命が
もう物事っていうのはずっとスピードで同じスピードで変化していくんだと
ウパニシャッドアッドアッドっていうのは止まってはいない
永遠ではないという意味で意味なんですけど
いわゆる止まっていないということなんですね
物事何一つも止まっていない
だから世間で言ってるこのもう金儲かりますよ
金儲かりましょうという教えよりも
一行目もものすごいレベル高い教えなんで宇宙意識で語ってるんだから
何一つも止まってるものはない
全部破壊へ向いて歩いてるんだと
ものすごい勢いで すべてのもの
一切は だから新しいものが現れて
それも破壊へ行く また新しいものが現れて
また破壊へ行く それだけの世界でしょうにと
だったらもう人生は金儲けて儲けていくことだけですと決めたことと
この考え方で言ったらものすごい違いますよ
それ 2番目 それで王様がアッチリアンボラットパルアブタ王様よくわかるんですね
自分のことだから ヤワスバシタンチダンテーナカタハグワタジャナタパサタラタサンマサンブッデーナウパニシャッドアッドオティ
なんとお釈迦様が阿羅漢大阿羅漢である正覚者であるお釈迦様がなんとすごいことをおっしゃっているんでしょうかと
彼が認めるんですね ササンジャンテコボラットパライマスミンラジャコレハッティカヤアピアッサカヤアピラタカヤアピパッティカヤアピアンマカンアパダス
ーパリヨーダヤワッティサンティアッタノーロークアナビッスローティイティバハンラッタパロアーハイマスサパナボラットパルバシタッサカタンアットダッタポータ
次の訳は何でしょうか
世界は守護者がないもの
保護者がいないもの  190 の 4行目からです
一応 3行目からラッタパールソンジャよ
この王家に  馬軍の車輪の法も悪い
兵舎ですね 兵舎はおやめの災害を防ぐために役立つ
だから王様から見れば
なんで保護 いわゆる守られ守られてないと思いますかと
王様一人だけにしたっても
ものすごい軍隊がいるでしょうにと
守ってくれるために 何かあったらちゃんと守ってくれるんだよと
ですから 自分にとってはこの意味がわからないんですね
この世は守られてないんだという意味はね
そこで大王そのことをどう思いますか？つまり
あなたは何らかの慢性的な病気があるのか？ということです
王様に直接聞くんですね
なんかあんたに病気でもありますかと
言ったらラッタパーラソンジャよ
私には慢性的な病気があります
ラッタパーラソンジャよ
ある時には友人 近親族
今やコーラビョウは攻撃をされるに違いない
そう立っておりました
この病気にかかっちゃったら
やっぱりもうダメでしょうと
みんな黙ってるんですね
どうにもならなくて 大王よ
そのことを  つまりあなたは友人親族院で私にわが尊敬すべき友人親族院で立ち会ってもらいたい
私の苦痛が軽減するように
ここにいるすべての者がこの苦痛を共有してほしいと言うことができるのかということだ
それともあなただけが続けますか
そういう話で まあすごい簡単単純で聞くんですね
大王様にはもう大変慢性的な病気があって
ものすごいもう倒れちゃいますね
苦しくて 倒れたらみんなどうにもならなくて
これで王様がもう終わりでしょうということで待ってるだけで悲しくて待ってるだけなんですけど
だったらあんたみんな呼んで苦痛を分けてもらいなさいよと
それはありえないんですね
ラッタパーラソンジャ私はその友人知人たちに
だけ移るようにここに移せるのは共有してほしいということができません
できません 私だけ  私 だからもういくら自分だけで
すごい苦痛を受けなくちゃいけないんです
そこが真理なんですね
だから守りはない世界ですよ
それなのに我々はものすごく守りの哲学で生きているんですよ
神様が守ってくれる お天道様が守ってくれるとかね
守る軍隊の大きいことをやおうよその神々もいるし
で また新しい守り神を輸入もするし
アメリカから フランスから
インドからとかね で もう少々時間経つとね
火星からも輸入するでしょうね
で 人類の初めから今までみんなこれ守ってくれる
これが私を守ってくれるとかね
本当のところ 正直なところ守ってくれてないんですよ
誰か証拠ありますかね？神様守ってくれて
なんとかうまくいったっていうことは
そういうケース一つもないんです
例えば人が雪山に行って
もう雪崩に巻き込まれたところで
神様手を出したらいいよ
私はあんたを捕まえておきますからと
じゃあ村に行きますよと
遭難したったらそこで死ぬか
こちらの救助レスキュー隊が行って救助するか
どちらかでしょうに 守ってくれませんよ
じゃあレスキュー隊守ってくるかというと
やはりそういう一つも当てにならない
自分が携帯電話持っていても電池が上がっちゃうと
それまたそれで終わっちゃうし
それでまあそれは電池が電気がつなげて連絡行ったっても
もうものすごい大雪の場合とかね
レスキュー隊には移動できないし
それで朝まで待たなくちゃいけないし
まあそういうふうなことで
人間の中でいろいろ我々お互いに助け合っていることはあるんだけど
そのいつでもリミットというものがありますからね
だからこの仏教は この守りに頼る生き方っていうのはね
あまり認めないんです
お守りはもう何もやってくれないんだと
お守りのところか 我々病気になったら
もうそんなに自分のことを心配するんだったら
じゃあ半分これ痛みぐらいね
もらってくれと言ったって
それは無理でしょうに
もらいたいんだけど 場合でもらえないんだからね
時々人間の間で この頭をあまりにも心配して
人の病気自分に移す場合ありますよ
あれはあまりよくない
子供にも時々ありますね
例えば母親とかね 何か病気で悩んでいると
子供たちがもう何もできないんですけど
すごく心配しちゃうんですね
そこで子供同じ病気にかかってしまっちゃうんですね
それで母親は助かるかというと逆でしょうに
母親は自分の病気を置いてて
子供の病気に手を出さなくちゃいけなくなっちゃうし
でも子供の病気は心理学的なものだから
いくら薬あげたって効いてくれないし
まあそれでもたもっと大変な苦しみになるだけ
だから人の病気 ただ軸案事で自分が病気になったって
それもえらい迷惑なんですよ
一人が病気だったら 周りがものすごいピンピン元気の方が一番いいんです
もうなんとかもう助けてくれるんだからね
私はいろいろ時々そういうケースを見たんだから
特にこの喘息とかね 場合はすごいきついんですよ
もう発作出てきたら 子供たちが自分の両親とか喘息で発作起こしちゃうと
もうそれ見ていられないんですね
それでも何か知らないうちに自分たちにもそれ出てきちゃうんです
で もうみんな心配 いくつかケースはありますけど
これはもうおかしいんだからね
こいつらに言ってあげなさいよと
いい加減にしないかと
もうやっぱり小さい時無理ですけどね
やっぱり心配するんだから
ちょっと大きくなっちゃうとね
おかしいことするなよと言ったら
やっぱりちょっと心が直って
それで病気治るんです
で でもその間 またあの劇薬毒薬を飲まなくちゃいけなくなっちゃうでしょうに
だからまあそれは別なこちらに関係ないケースなんですけど
というのは 自分の病気は自分で苦しめなくちゃいけない
自分が死ぬ時は誰も守ってくれませんということが事実です
この法 ラッタパーラ尊者がこの法には莫大な黄金金貨が大地のものとしても虚空のものとしてもあります
しかし 世界は自己の所有がなく
すべてを捨てていかねばならないとラッタパーラ尊者は言われました
うん  この言葉の意味はどのように理解されるべきでしょう
続けていいでしょ  大王よ
そのことをどう思いますか？つまり
あなたは今 五種の能力を与えられ
備え楽しんでいますが
そのようにあの世でもあなたは全く同じように
私は五種の能力を与えられ
備え楽しむということができるのかということです
それとも 他の者たちがこの財を引き継ぎ
あなたは業に従っていくことになるのかということです
うん  ラッタパーラ尊者よ
私は今 五種の能力を与えられ
備え楽しんでいますが
そのようにあの世でも私は全く同じように五種の能力を与えられ
備え楽しむということはできません
他の者たちがこの財を引き継ぐことになり
ただ私は業に従っていくことになります
それでそういうことになるんだと
財産というものは自己の所有がないんだと
全部捨てますよと言っても
王様が私はすごい金持ちでしょうと
いくらでも楽しくて生活できるんだよと言ったら
じゃああなたは死んじゃったら
このあなた この財産持っていくんですか？あるいはあなた死んでもその財産を喜ぶことできるかと
だからそれできません
自分が死んじゃったら
自分一人で死ぬだけであって
あの王様の全ての財産が誰か誰か他の人が自分のものにするだけなんです
ですから 我々の持ち物がないんですよ
全部捨てていかなくちゃいけない
自分の業だけですね 持っていけるのは
ですから 私たちもちょっと考えちゃって
この財産とかいろいろあるんですけど
これ私のもの 私のものと言っても
それは勘違いであって
私が死んだ瞬間で私のものではないんですね
ですから 私のものって成り立たないんですね
死んだ 息が止まったその瞬間から
じゃああなたのものじゃない
それは他の誰かのものになる
ですから 自分のものというものはありえないんだと
そういう そういうことなのに
みんなこの地球のゴミをね
いじっていじっては固めて集めては置いておく
みんな金儲けてそういうことでしょうね
やっているのはね みんなで適当に使えばいい地球の財産ですけど
それは 1箇所に 1箇所にもう好き勝手に集めて集めて
これが私のものだとかね
この国は隣の国よりは豊かで金持ちですよとかね
それで隣の国を潰してやるぞとか言ったりして
一人一人人間には何一つ持ってないでしょうね
ですから みんな一人一人の人間として生きてるんだから
何も持ち物はないんですね
そのまま死んでしまっちゃう
ですから 業だけですね
やった自分の行為 善行為
いいことしたならばそれだけ持っていけるんですからね
ですから 大きな部屋はもう 10個ぐらいある家を作るよりも
徳を積んだ方が自分のものになるんです
あれは誰かにあげるためのことだからね
最初からの考えが 例えば 30年のローンを組んで家を作って
誰かにあげるために家を作るんだと
それ自体バカバカらしいでしょうに
いえ 私の家だからと思ったら作られるんですね
私が住むんだからと思ったら作られますけど
そういうおかしい考え方がないと作られません
ないんですね そこで自分がローンを組んで家を作っても
自分が死んだ瞬間から自分のものじゃないんです
ですから この世の中で何一つも自分のものになるものはありませんという教えで
4番目に終わっちゃう
あ またもう一つありますね
ウーノローカティットというね
はい 日本語でいきましょう
892の半ばからですが
世界は借ることのない
貸すことのない 立会の奴隷であるとラッタパーラ尊者は言われました
この語られた言葉の意味はどのように理解されるべきでしょうか？大王よ
そのことをどう思いますか？つまり
あなたは繁栄しているクル国に住んでいるのかということです
ラッタパーラ尊者はその通りです
私は繁栄しているクル国に住んでいます
大王よ そのことをどう思いますか？つまり
ここに信頼すべき誠実な人は東方からあなたのところへやってきたとします
彼はあなたにこう言います
大王よ どうかお知りください
私は東方から来ましたが
そこで栄え富み 種多く人々で賑わっている広大な地方を見ました
そこには多くの象軍 馬軍
車軍 歩軍がおります そこには多くの財宝
穀物があります そこには天然の
また加工された多くの黄金
金貨があります そこには多くの女性がおります
しかも 当面の兵力だけで征服することができます
大王よ 征服してください
あなたならそれをどうするのかということです
ラッタパーラ尊者よ 我々はそれを征服し
住むことになります 大王よ
そのことをどう思いますか？つまり
ここに信頼すべき誠実な人が西方からあなたのところへやってきたとします
彼はあなたにこう言います
西方から来ましたが 同じような国があって
しかも征服できますよと
大王よ 征服してください
あなたならそれをどうするのかということです
ラッタパーラ尊者よ 我々はそれを征服し
住むことになります 北方から来ます
北方も当面の兵力だけで征服することができます
征服してください あなたならそれをどうしますか？ラッタパーラ尊者よ
我々は征服します 同じく南方からやってきます
南方からの国も楽に征服できます
大王よ どうしますか？ラッタパーラ尊者よ
我々がそれを征服します
海からですね  海もありますか？そう
海の彼方からですね  海の彼方からあなたのところへやってきたとします
海の彼方の地方にもそういう国があって
征服しやすいのですが
どうしましょうかと ラッタパーラ尊者よ
我々はそれを征服し 住むことになります
大王よ このことについて
死を語るお方であるアラカン小自覚者であるカノセソンは
世界は当たることのない
飽くことのない渇愛の奴隷であると語られました
そういうことでね だからこの王様に直接あんたどう思いますか？とね
隣の 例えば東の方でものすごい豊かな国がありまして
もうでもあまり兵力はないんだと
簡単に征服できますよと言ったら
だったら取りますよと
で 東西南北どちらから来たっても
もうそれでも取るんだよと
最初に王様に聞いた あんた今の国はものすごい素晴らしい国で
完璧でしょう 満たしてます
そうですよと こんなに豊かな国で王になってもう満足やと
吾輩は だからちょっと聞きますけど
もし東から誰がこんな話持ってきたらどうします？と
それだったら取りますよと
東西南北だけじゃなくて
海の彼方からでも何か国があると聞いちゃったら
それも取るんだから切りがないでしょうね
だから王様にとってもそういうことで
現代我々もそういうこと
アメリカの人にもそういうこと
いくら力が広げたっても
まだ足らない まだ足らないということで
もっともっと潰して潰してはいく
我々もいくらお金あったって
これで十分ということは絶対成り立たないんですね
もっとあればいいんじゃないかなと
だからそこはすごい引っ掛け罠なんですよ
心の だから人間 ずっと死ぬまで何を感じているかというと
足らない 足らない 足らない
もっとあった方がいいんだという病気で悩んでるんですよ
だからみんな時々言うでしょ？なんて幸せですか？とか
あれ本当でしょうか？と私は聞きたいんですよ
生きていて生きていてよかったとかね
やっぱり自分が人生にものすごく満足しているんですよとかね
今の人生でとかね 本当にあんた本当のことを言ってるんですかと
おかしいんじゃないかと聞きたくなっちゃうんです
それで時々テレビのインタビューなんかでは
まあ現代日本人の状況とかね
今現代の生活状況については満足していますとインタビューすると
まあやはり不思議に 摩訶不思議で
七十パー 六十パーセント満足しているというアンケート出るでしょう
あれほど嘘世の中にありますかね
そういう人々も殺菌しているし
泥棒もするし いろんなことやってるし
賄賂も取っているし 親と喧嘩するしね
財産のために で もう会社でものすごく競争しているし
もっと上の方へ上がりたい
もっと上に上がりたいとかね
そんなことやってるのに満足だと
誰一人も人間には満足というのは感じられないものなんですよ
ずっと感じられない もっとあった方がいいという
この貧しさなんですよ
それでおかしいことに
この豊かになればなるほど
貧しさの気持ちがものすごく強化するんです
だから精神的にどちらが貧しいというと
この第三国々の人々よりも日本の人々が精神的に貧しいんです
で それがもっと激しくなる
もっと豊かなアメリカとかになってくると
だから物質的に豊かになればなるほど
我々精神的に貧しさがどんどん強くなっちゃうんですね
だって自分の国だったら十万円あれば一人の子供の一年
二年間の教育面倒を全部見てあげることできます
何のことなく すごいもう贅沢もさせちゃって
日本で子供一人で十万円あったら何ができるんですかね
大したことできないでしょうに
だから自分の子供にすごく贅沢させて
いろいろもういろんなことを道具を揃えてあげてね
気楽に勉強させたいと思ったら
これたくさんのお金が必要になっちゃうんですね
例えば英語でもペラペラ喋ってほしいと思っちゃうと
あのー あのインターナショナルスクールなんかに入れておかなくちゃあかんでしょうに
そうすると払うべき学費とか考えてみると
でもあれの百分の一で貧しい国でできますよ
そういうレベルの教育とかね
時々日本で宣伝するでしょ
例えばこの百円があれば
あの百円寄付すれば あのー
あの何でしたか 注射 ワクチンですね
五十人のワクチンできます
五十人の子供の命を救われますよと
このユネスコのね 宣伝で言ってるでしょうね
それを事実なんですよ
百円で買うワクチンで五十人ぐらいの子供たちの命を助けてあげることができますし
でも じゃあ日本でも百円で済みますかね
それは 日本の場合はちょっと風邪ひいたら
まあ一万五千ぐらいは飛んじゃうんでしょうに
だから見てください 日本でも子供が風邪ひいた
貧しい国にも一人の子供が
二人とも同じ人間でしょうに
でも足らないと必要ということはこちらの方がすごく多いんです
その額を第三の国の人が聞いたら
もう飛び上がるでしょう
驚いて それぐらいお金がかかるんですかと
ですから やっぱりそういう罠なんですよ
例えば大きな家を造ったとしましょう
それがその維持するべき
何かちょっと壊れた時の修理とか
どれぐらいお金がかかりますかね
まあ庭付きですよと思ったら
もう毎年庭仕事をやとなくちゃあかんでしょうに
それでまたずっとお金が必要になっちゃうんです
まあなんとかして一億円
一億円空から落ちてきたんだから
じゃあ大きな家を造りましょうと
で 造ったのはいいんだけど
それからはもっと今の給料は足らなくなっちゃうんです
造ったものを維持するために
ですから 豊かさの裏に必ずもうもっと強力な貧しさっていうのが付いてるんですよ
だから心の中では足らない
足らない 足らない もっとあってほしいという気持ちからは
いくら踏ん張っても脱出はできません
このやり方でいくら踏ん張っても
だから安らぎは感じないんです
あの王様は騙されてるだけ
私はすごい豊かな クル国っていうのはかなり豊かな国なんです
当時でインディアと十六の国の中でクルという国はものすごく豊かな国でしたから
それなのに私はクル国の王様よと思ってたっても
ちょっといじってみたら
そんな心のやっぱり満たしてないということはわかるんでしょうね
ですから お釈迦様は誰にも
あの変えることできない絶対的な真理を語りましたと
人類については それを聞いて
聞いて やっぱりこのみんな言うことをやっちゃうと無意味だと
ただ苦しみ増えることだと
だからブッダの話を聞いて理解して出家したんだと
王様は四つの項目もよくわかりました
もう年でしょうしね それで経典は終わりますけど
あの偈で あの全部まとめて偈で終わっちゃうんですね
パッサミローケサタネマヌッセラッダナヴィッタムナダダンティモーハルッダハダナンサニッチャヤンカロンテビーヨワカーメアビパッタヤンティ
パッサミローケサタネマヌッセ
この世の中で財産ある人々は私に見えます
ラッダナヴィッタムナダダンティモーハ
でも愚か者だからいっぱいお金あるのに人に配ってあげない
お布施はしないと その代わりにルッダハダナンサニッチャヤンカロンテ
さらに金儲かるんだと
自分に財産ある人々いる
自分に財産あるんだったらもう配れというのが仏教の考え方なんですよ
こんなもの危ないんだと
もう持っていけないんだ
だから配れと いわゆるお布施しなさいと
誰にでもいいんだからと
それなのに財産家の人何するかというと
頭が悪いんだからもっと儲かることにするんだと
ビーヨワカーメアビパッタヤンティ
もっともっと欲しいと欲を希望するんだと
ラージャパサイハパテヴィンウィジットワササジャランタンマヒンアワサントウオーランサムッダッサアピッテルーポーパランサムッダッサピパッタイエータ
ラージャパサイハ 力強い国っていう
パテヴィンウィジットワ
いわゆる暴力でね 王様が暴力でこのある国をかってしまって
海まで いわゆる東西南北
海までもう戦争して戦争して
暴力を振るって 国々全部自分の国にすると
それでもオーランサムッダッサ
海の向こうの国も欲しがっちゃうんだと
そんなことを世の中でよくあったことだからね
日本も結構失敗しましたからね
その傷跡でいまだに痛いでしょうし
[笑い]ラージャチェアンニェーチェバフーマヌッサアヴィータタンハマラナンウペンティ
ウーナワフットワナジャハンティデーハンカーメーヒローカンヒナハッティティッティ
それすごく綺麗な文章を入れて
みんな覚えていただきたかったんですね
覚えてここら辺は唱えてみてくださいと
これは頭が綺麗に良くなりますよってことでね
ラージャチェアンニェーチェバフーマヌッサアヴィータタンハマラナンウペンティ
ラージャチェ 王様 アンニェーチェバフーマヌッサ
他の王政の人々 すべての人々が
アヴィータタンハ 渇愛が消えないまま
マラナンウペンティ いわゆる欲しがるまんまで死んでしまう
もっと欲しい もっと欲しいと思うままに死んでしまっちゃう
ウーナワフットワナジャハンティデーハン
ナジャハンティデーハンってなってくるとちょっと意味がわからなくなります
え？フットワはフットワで
うん でしょうね フットワナという言葉もありますけどね
これ分けてるんだから何かおかしくなっちゃうんですね
でもワあるんだからウーナワフットワなんですね
言葉はね この「わ」抜けちゃうと「フットワーナ」でいくんですけどね
でもミャンマー版で「わ」じゃなくて違う言ったりしますからね
まあどうかわからない
でも意味があまり いつでもその問題にぶつかります
そこでこの「ウーナーワフットワー」も満たしてない状態でみんな体は捨てるんだと
みんな死ぬんだけど 我輩は満足だという気持ちでは誰一人も死にません
やりたいこと したいことをいっぱい残したまんまで
もうみんな人類が死ぬんですよ
カーメーヒローキャンミーナアッティティッティ
欲には一度も満足ということはないんだと
満たすということはないんだと
カンダンティナンヤーティパキリーヤケーセアホーワターネーアマラーティチャフー
ワッテーネナンパールタンミーハリトワチッタンサマーダーヤタトーダハンティ
カンダンティっていうのは泣く
ヤーティパキリーヤケーセ
髪の毛をね こうやって出してみんな泣くんだと
アホーワターネーアマラーティニャーチャフー
何でしたっけ あれは 死んでしまったとかね
という 親族が誰か死んじゃったら
もう本当に何で死んでしまったんでしょうか？とかね
何でおじいさん死んでしまったんでしょうかと言って
もう髪の毛こうしながらよく泣くんですけど
結局はその死体をまた何かに巻いて燃やしちゃうでしょう
言ってることやってることは何でしたっけ？と
ワッテーネナンパールタンミーハリトワチッタンサマーダーヤチッタンサマハダヤタトーダハンティ
だから本当におかしいんですよ
例えば何でお母さん死んだったんでしょうとか
泣きながらまだ泣くんですね
だからあの泣きが正直でしょうかとね
本当に死に奉仕が来なかったら
もう焼いてもらいたくないということになるんだけどね
ソーダイヘティスーレイヒプッジャマヌエーケーネワッテーネパハヤボーゲ
これインドの葬式のやり方なんですね
これはインドだけでやることで
人が死んだらこの一枚の布で体を巻いて持っていくんですよ
持って行ってこの薪の上に置いておくんですね
スリランカでそんなことやりませんですけど
薪の上にちょっとした薪なんですけど
ちょっと薪を固めてその上に入れておいて
下から火をかけると それでこの薪からもう頭とか足とか飛び出してるでしょうに
それ全部焼いて焼けませんと薪が落ちるとまたあっちこっち体がね
よけたりしますから それで何か鉄の釘を持って刺したり刺したりして
全部中にこっちから下ろして中に入れたりして
いろいろ無茶苦茶なことをして全部燃やしちゃうんですよ
かなり無礼ですよ インドの火葬のやり方は
だからこの見せてくれない
観光で行っても ガンジスとかのガハトなんかみんな観光にいらっしゃるでしょ
その時はこの火葬場がありますけど
見せてはくれません もうすごい尊い場所だって
燃やす時に何の尊くもなく
ただポーンと放り投げて
もうもうもういろいろなことをして燃やしちゃって
それは灰をね 川に流しちゃうんです
ガンジス川に それで天国に行くんです
何の問題もなく ですから
いくらもう億万長者であろうが
葬式はそんなやり方でやるんだからね
だから何でしょうかとね
あなたの財産 あれは葬式の決まりだから
億万長者だからもうちょっと何か丁寧にということになります
それはない だからお釈迦様が亡くなる時は
自分の葬式のやり方はちゃんと決めておいたんです
こういう風に王様にやるようにちゃんとやりなさいと
鉄の鉄器を作って その中にこの香りの油を入れて
その中に体を綿と布で巻いて
何枚何枚その中に入れて
また鉄の蓋として という順番があります
そういう風にお釈迦様の葬式をやりましたけどね
で それで骨は全部綺麗に残りましたし
シャリだけ 普通はそういう死に方
火葬のし方なんですね
それでお坊さんたちも時々この瞑想修行を怠けたりすると
それで言って叱るんですよ
あんた修行怠けて悟らないで死んじゃうと
あなた死んじゃったらただそうやってあちこちでもう刺されて刺して折ったりして
ただ燃やしてそのまま捨てるんだよと
悟ったならば大変丁寧に火葬して
そのあなたをあなたに礼をするんだと
ですから どちらにするかと考えなさいよと
ただそこら辺で誰かがね
もう任せてあげて そこで好き勝手に燃える
燃やしちゃう 時々その火葬の受ける側が二体受けちゃったら
同じ薪のため全部二体も放り出しちゃって燃やす場合もあります
誰の誰かとそんな関係ない
一旦死んじゃったら そんなもうあまりもう遺体に対しては全然もう興味ないというかね
それはインドの文化で
でも悟った人の場合はそうじゃない
それはものすごい特別扱いして
この遺体も火葬場でもなくて
大変丁寧な聖地と思えるところに持っていって
そこでみんなでもう大変礼をして火葬して
もう尊敬する もう灰もシャリもちゃんと別にして貰って
それにもストゥーパやらね
仏塔を作ったりもする
ですからもうすごい差が激しいんです
それでお坊さんたちも怠けちゃうと
それインドで昔言ったみたいですね
あなたはどちらにするか決めなさいよと
だから死ぬことは確実だから
それはよく言ってあげるんですね
ナミ
ーエマナスセババンティターナニャーティデミッターアテヴァーサハヤーダーヤーデカータッセダナンハランティーサットーパナガッチェティエーナカンマンナミーエマナスセババンティターナ
死んでいく人にとっては何も頼りになるものはないと
ニャーティ 親戚がいたっても助けてくれない
ミッター 友達いても助けてくれない
好き人がいても誰も助けてくれない
生きてる間はいっぱいいるんだけどね
もう何とかあったら言ってくださいよと
死んでるところは誰も何もやってくれない
ダーヤーデカータッセダナンハランティ
相続のする連中が来て
いきなりお金持って帰っちゃうんですね
もう死んだ人はもうあっち行けという感じで
だから全部お金持っていくと
サットーパナガッチェティエーナカンマン
死んだ人はただ自分の行いだけ持ってあの世に行かなくちゃいけないんですよと
結局自分がやった善行為
悪行為 それだけ持っていかなくちゃいけないんですね
ナミーエマナンダナマンヴェティキンチプッターチャダーラーチャダナンチャラッタン
ナディーガマーヨンラバテーダネーナナチャーピヴィッテーナジャランヴィハンティ
ナミーエマナンダナンアンヴェティキンチ
死んでる人はお金で買えるものは何もないんだと
という意味でしょうね
プッターチャダーラーチャダナンチャラッタン
死んでる人が子供たちからもらうもの何もない
ダーラーっていうのはおそらく女の子たちでしょうね
でお金 財産とか国とかあっても
死んでる人にとってはそれは何にもできませんということですよ
日本語どうですか？私のはちょっとおかしくなっちゃった
死にゆく者に財 子とか
妻子財産王国もまた一緒に行ってくれないということでしょうか
えっと まあね アンウェーティっていうのはやっぱり一緒に来るという意味もありますね
そうです その訳が楽です
で 死んでいく人にとってはお金も一緒についてこないし
子供たちも国も財産も誰一人も一緒についてこない
全部自分を見放しちゃうんです
その場合は ナ・ディーガ・マーユン・ラバテー・ダネーナ
お金で長寿を買うことは全然できません
ナチャアピ・ヴィッテーナ・ジャラン・ジャハン
それから財産あるんだからといって年取ることをやめてもらうと
で それはできません だからできればみんな商売やってるでしょうね
10万で一年減ってあげるぞとかね
アッパン・ヒダン・ジーヴィタ・マー
ху・ディーラー・アサッサ・タン・ヴィッパリナーマ・ダンマ・アッダー・ダリンダー・チェ・プサンティ・パッサン・バーロー・チェ・ディーロー・チェ・タテーヴァ・プットー
アッパン・ヒダン・ジーヴィタン
この生きているっていうことは
ほんのわずかな時間のことでしょうしとディーラー
賢者が言うんですよ アサッサ・タン・ヴィッパリナーマ・ダンマ
命ということはものすごくこのアサッサ・タンというのは永遠でないということで
無常という儚いものということですね
変わってしまいますよと
ちょっとしたことで死にますから
生きる時間も短いし それまたもう不安定で
いつ死ぬかわからないというものでしょうと
そこでアッダー・ダリッダー・チェ・プサンティ・パッサン
バーロー・チェ・ディーロー・チェ・タテーヴァ・プットー
アッダー 豊かな人も貧乏な人も死にますよと
死に出会いますよと プサンティ・パッサンというのは
バーロー・チェ 愚か者も賢者も同じく死ぬ時は死ぬんだよと
バーローヒ・バーラーヤ・ワディトーヴァ・セーティ・ディーロー・チェナ・ヴェーダティ・パッサ・プットー
タスマーヒ・パンニャーヴァ・ダネーナ・セイヨー・ヤーヤ・ヴォーサーナン・イダ・イダー・ディガッチャティ
バーローヒ・バーラーヤ・ワディトーヴァ・セーティ
愚か者がこの死に対してすっごく悩むんですね
死迎えてくると いわゆる死にかけてくると
すごく悩んだり混乱したりする
ディーロー 賢者は全然気にしない
これから死にますか？ということで平気でいる
タスマーヒ・パンニャーヴァ・ダネーナ・セイヨー
ですから お金よりは知恵がすごいと
人間が何を獲得するべきかというと
知恵を獲得しなさいよと
知恵を得なさいと 金じゃないんだと
だって愚か者が 知恵がない人が死に死になってくると
もう泣いたりわめいたり
恐怖感で覆われたりして混乱しちゃうでしょうに
知恵のある人はそうじゃあ死ぬんですかね
これから私がと なんのことなく冷静にいるんだから
ああそう 当たり前だからということで落ち着けていますね
ですから それをお金にできないんですよ
精神安定 安定 精神的な落ち着きというのお金で得られるものじゃないですから
金より知恵ですよと
アソーシ・タッターヒ・バワー・バヴェースー・パーパーニ・カンマーニ・カロン・ティ・モーハー・ウペーティ・ガッバン・チェ・パラン・チェ・ローカン・サンサーラ・マーパッジャ・パラン・パラヤ
アソーシ・タッターっていうのはまだ欲してないという
まだまだ欲がある 欲が消えてない
生きていきたい 生きていきたいと
もっともっと長生きしたい
もう死にたくはないというふうに欲がまだ満たせない
欲が消えてないんだから
パーパーニ・カンマーニ・カロン・ティ
悪行をするんだと みんな
だってみんな生きていきたいんだから
悪いことばっかりしているでしょうに
だから欲が消えてないんだから
一生懸命悪行をするんだと
モーハー 愚かでありますから
だからウペーティ・ガッバン・チェ・パラン・チェ・ローカン
死んでも終わらないんですね
ウペーティ・ガッバン
どこかのお腹の中に入ってしまう
生まれ変わってしまった
パラン・ローカ あの世の中でまた生まれ変わっちゃう
サンサーラ・マーパッジャ・パラン・パラヤ
それからずっと続けて輪廻するんだと
ですから 人がこれで死んで終われば幸せなのに
終われないんですよ で
やっぱりもっと長生きしたいという気持ちあるでしょうに
もっと元気でいたいと
だから死ぬ時も自分が満たしてない乾く状態でいるんですね
それで悪いことをする
そうするとさらに悪いところに生まれ変わったりする
生まれ変わったらまた一からやり直し
生まれた瞬間から年取っていくんだから
ああ 年取りたくない 病気になりたくないとか
金儲かりたい 金儲かりたい
また同じことをやって
またやっぱり金儲かりたかったのに
もっと長生きしたかったのに
もう死ぬんですか？と言って
もう怯えて死んで また生まれ変わって
また初めからやり直しと
それでそれが輪廻と言うんですね
だから生まれ変わることは全く愚か者の行為なんです
タッサッパパンニョアビサッダハントウウペティガッバンチェパランチェローカン
それでアッパパンニョ
パンニョ 智慧がない人はどんどん世の中生まれ変わるんだという意味です
チョーローヤターサンディムケーガヒートーサカッマナーハンニャティパーパダンモー
エワンパジャーペッチェパランミローケーサカッマナーハンニャティパーパダンモー
その泥棒が待ち構えているんだけど
自分を捕まえられちゃった
捕まれると まだ泥棒もしていないのに
でも捕まれたらもう自分が裁けられるんですね
それは自分が悪いことをしたんだからなんですね
そのようにパジャー 人々もペッチェパランミローケー
あの世の中に行ってから
自分の悪業で大変苦しみますよと
Yes I go
カーマーヒチットラマドゥラーマノーラマーヴィルーパルーペーナマテンティチッタンアーディーナワンカーマグネー スディス
ワ パスマアハンパッバジトーミラージャ
この偈は結構古い偈なんです
マイよりも カーマーヒチットラ
カーマ 欲っていうのは美しいで
マドゥーラ 大変美味しいもので
マノーラマ 心喜ばせるんだと
まあ現認尾比出身の欲の世界ですね
でもヴィルーパルーペーナマテンティチッタン
でもみんなこの変色 変
変質しているでしょうに
だってね いろいろお化粧したり
アクセサリーを着けたり
服を巻いたりして まあもう変質して
我々の心を あの 何て言いますか
マテンティ え？マテンティ
マテっていうのは何か駆け回すという
我々の心を駆け回すんだと
その欲の短所というかね
それ 裏はものすごい問題が
罠が仕掛けているんだという
この欲のデメリットですね
欲のデメリットを見て
私は出家したんだよと
ドゥマッパララーニ
ドゥマッパララーニパタンティマーンバダハラーチェブッダハチェシャリーラベーラーエタンピディスワパッバジトーミラージャアパンナカンサーマンニャンエーワセイヨ
ドゥマッパララーニ この熟したあの実ですね
もうポツンポツンと落ちるでしょうに
そのように まあ人間はね
子供であろうが老人であろうが
ポツンポツンと死んでしまいますと
ドゥマッパラって特別な
ただ熟した  みんな落ちて落ちて死ぬんだよと
それを見て私は出家しましたと
出家はアパンナカンサーマンニャン
アパンナカンっていうのは仏教
すごい威張って威張ってっていうのおかしいんだけど
使ってる言葉なんですね
もう選択のない道 唯一の道で
いわゆる中道ということなんで
中道っていうのはこれしかないんだぞというふうに発見する生き方なんですね
ですから 人間にはもう本当に解脱するしか
もう唯一の道がないんですよ
ただお金欲しくて捨てられないのは
それは弱みであって 財産欲しくて財産からもう離れられないのは弱みであって
友達がもうもう気に入って離れられない
それは弱みだけのことであって
人間にとってはそこら辺では何の救いもない
何の頼りもない 誰も助けてはくれない
自分が不幸になったら自分一人の世界で
ですから 一緒にいてもいなくなってもどうったことないんですよ
友達のところで一緒にいるんだと言って
じゃあ病気になったらどうなるんだよ
自分の一人だけの苦しみでしょうに
死んでしまうとか 自分一人で死ぬしかないでしょうに
それでまた輪廻転生してしまって苦労するでしょうし
ですから 人が選ぶべき道は
道は 唯一の道は出家であると決めて
私はこのアパンナカ道を疑問のない道
疑いを成り立たない道を選んだんだと
パンナカっていうのはクエスチョンであって
アパンナカっていうのはクエスチョンが成り立たないと
その経典は終わりますけど
その経典で この本当の内容はものすごい
私はその行だけ扱って預けて喋ったならば
もっとすごいすごいことを言いますけど
経典を読むことになりましたからね
淡々と内容だけ言ったんですけど
これこれも革命的な思想を教えてるんですよ
もう単純に聞こえるんだけど
人類の思考の道と それが仕掛けだと
罠だと それ全く違う道があるんだよということを教えているところなんです
ですから 私たちはもう昔
人類が始めた時からもう頑張れ
仕事をしれ 金儲けなさいとかね
財産作れというだけばっかり言ってくれたんだけど
それで誰一人満足して死んだわけじゃないんですよ
途中でも死んじゃうし
喧嘩やら戦争やら苦しみ
憂い そればっかりでしょうね
子供が病気になったら楽しいんでしょうかね
子供が先に死んじゃったら楽しいんですかね
そういう経験 人でいっぱいあるのに
どうしてもそういうことは避けられないし
それでももっと子供を作って
ものすごい豊かになりなさいとか言っとかいなって
毎日年取って死んでしまうし
ですから地球まで破壊して
この行く道がもうただの自分で自分で穴を掘って自分で落ちるようなことですよと
自分であっちこっち罠を仕掛けて
自分でサーッと走って引っかかってもらうっていうのは
これは別に賢くも何でもないんですよ
ですから その生き方はやめなさいよということなんですね
もっと違う生き方あるんだよと言って
お釈迦様は全ての人に出家しなさいということを言ってないしね
お釈迦様の弟子たちはもう出家していた人もあって
しなかった人もあって
財産の資産家たちもいっぱいいましたけど
みんなすごく喜びを感じて
ものすごい元気で明るくていていたいたんですね
財産がなくなったっても平気な気持ちで
で 増えてきたっても 別にもうあまりもうそうしたことはないという感じで
で 商売やるとこはちゃんと商売するんだけど
ものすごい執着はないんですね
ただ淡々と計算しながら
じゃあこれでこれでこれだったら儲かりません
だからじゃあこれぐらいにしましょうとかね
そういう淡々単純にも仕事をする
それで仏教徒だから 自分の仲間
仕事をしてくれる人々に対しても
すごく愛情と兄弟みたいな気持ちで接するでしょうね
それでみんなこの主人はもう大変父親ですよと思って
もう財産守ってくるんだから
これまたすごい気楽であるし
そういう平等な世界を作ったんだから
たとえ在家の人々でも
一旦ブッダの道に入ったところで
みんな並ならぬ安らぎ
生きる喜びを感じていたんですね
ストレスはない世界なんですね
これアナータピンディカこっちという人がね
もうある日布施ばっかりしてしまって
それで忙しくて商売に手を出すことができなかったんですね
それで借金取った人は金返してくれないわ
そこであっちこち借金はもう保管していたお金が消えちゃうとかね
あって貧乏になってきた
貧乏と言ったっても 一度もうちょっとものすごい経済状態悪化しちゃったんですね
そこで彼がもうお布施ばっかりしたんだから
私が貧乏になったんではないかと怒ったことがないんです
まあいいんじゃないかと
でも悲しいんですよと
何が悲しいんですか？という
やっぱり私はすごいお釈迦様にね
もうものすごくごちそうをそこで食べさせていたんだけど
お坊さんたちにも 今たった一つの汁と硬いご飯しかあげられないんだと
これめったもないんだと
なんでいいお布施できないかって
そればっかり悩んでるんです
それでまたいろいろ工夫して
せん坊かに戻りましたけどね
だからといって別にどうったことはないという
みんなそういう人な人々でしたからね
コーサラ王様がこのお釈迦様に対して大変信頼してて
悟るは悟りはしなかったんだけどね
まあちょっと出来が悪い王様でも説法は聞くんだけど
帰ってからまたくだらないことを何か悪いことをやっちゃうんですね
それでも一番一番大きい国でしたし
一番強様でしたし だからお釈迦様にも何もできませんしね
で 歳ぐらいになったところで
すごい体も病気で やっぱりこそこそとお釈迦様のところに行くんですよ
もう誰も相手にしてくれる人もいないし
で 国の権利は自分の息子が誰かが一応やってますけど
王ではないんですね 全部一応管理費はやってるんだけど
これこの人は自分が王ということで
自分のこの指輪とベルトとこちらにつけるものと刀ですね
それは王の象徴するものですから
それだけ誰にもあげない
それを死んでから息子に儀式を通して与えるものだから
勝手に使ってはいけないという決まりなんです
だから この老人になった王様が友達人と大臣人と連れて行って
これも持ってお釈迦様のところに行ったんです
最後の挨拶に だからその品物を持って行ったんです
その品物を持って それも体につけて
お釈迦様に礼をしましょうと
それでいて お釈迦様の足を自分の手で触れながら
私はこのコーサラ国の大王ですと言って
また礼をする また立ち上がって
私はコーサラ国の大王がお釈迦様に礼をいたしますと
また礼をするんです そこで個人としてではなくて
王としてもお釈迦様に礼をしたいという気持ちなんですね
言って またお釈迦様の足を触ってね
お釈迦様その時はもう年でした
そうするとお釈迦様はね
あなた大王 なんでこの体にそんなに礼をするんですか？と言ったら
自分がいかにお釈迦様のおかげで助けてきたんですかということでいろいろ言うんですね
その話をして お釈迦様と仲良く喋っていると
お釈迦様の前で礼をするというか
あれ全部品物 道具外したったんですね
外して大臣に渡してあげて
それから礼をしたんです
その大臣がこそこそと後ろに下がっちゃって
あれ持って行っちゃったんです
持っていって宮殿に入ったんです
あのものあると宮殿に入られるんです
というのに入ったらもう一応クーデターですよ
で まあ次の王は決めちゃった
決められたんだけどね
王様が見たらもう誰もいない
でも全然全く平気でこそこそと歩いていて
宮殿のところに行ったら立ち入り禁止
あんた誰ですかと 誰も顔見たことがないんだから
他の人々は王と王の顔なんか見ないんだから
そしたら中に入らなくて
その夜亡くなっちゃったんです
ですから やっぱりそれでもその人は決してものすごい幸せ
死んじゃいましたからね
だからまあ 本人は悲しくはない
ブッダに会ってお釈迦様と話し合って
これこそ自分にとっては幸福で幸せで喜びだよと
だから たとえコーサラ大王様であろうが
財産っていうのはそんなもんなんですね
死ぬ瞬間でもう家にも入れられなくて
外で普通の旅人たちやらみんな泊まるところで横になって
だからね ですから このやっぱり人間っていうのは
心の安らぎっていうことを目指して頑張るべきですよっていう話でしょうし
この経典は出家することで意味を成してますからね
だから若者たちも結構元気に出家しちゃったんです
だから あれは誰も逃げたわけじゃないんです
仏教の出家は逃げてはできるものじゃないんですね
ものすごい修行もそれなりに大変智慧が必要し
頑張らなくちゃいけないしね
で とにかく仏教の出家はちょっと訳が違うと
他の宗教の場合はみんな失敗する人々のたまり場なんですけどね
そういうたまり場ではないんだと
これは勝利者の集まって集まるところですよと
チャレンジする戦士たちの訓練場であって
たまり場ではないということなんです
で 話がもう非常に長くなりました
申し訳ございません どうもありがとうございました